la incontinencia urinaria es una pérdida
involuntaria de orina si las terapias
menos invasivas no mejoran los síntomas
el médico puede recomendar cirugía para
este problema común el sistema urinario
incluye los riñones los uréteres la
vejiga y la uretra
y la orina que consta de agua y residuos
filtrados fluye a través de los uréteres
hasta la vejiga urinaria un órgano
muscular expandible donde se almacena la
orina durante la micción la orina sale
del cuerpo a través de la uretra los
músculos especiales que se encuentran en
la base de la vejiga denominados
esfínteres ayudan a controlar la
liberación de la orina ya sea relajando
para iniciar el flujo o contrayendo para
detener el flujo la mayoría de cirugías
que se realizan sin complicaciones toman
alrededor de una hora y requieren
anestesia general o espinal en una
suspensión abdominal de vejiga abierta
el cirujano empezará realizando una
incisión en el abdomen sobre la vejiga
luego es cirujano suturar a la uretra y
el cuello vesical próximo a la pared del
hueso pélvico u otras estructuras
cercanas
al cambiar la ubicación y el ángulo de
la uretra la orina tiene menos tendencia
a fluir fácilmente bajo presión
como una alternativa a la cirugía
abierta algunas veces se realiza
suspensión laparoscópica de la vejiga en
un proceso laparoscópica se inserta un
endoscopio con la interna cámara y
pequeños instrumentos quirúrgicos
mediante incisiones diminutas en el
abdomen
en un procedimiento de cabestrillo el
cirujano comenzará realizando dos
pequeñas incisiones una en la vagina y
otra en el abdomen
y la incisión vaginal dejará a la vista
la uretra y la vejiga próxima la
incisión abdominal dejará a la vista una
pieza resistente de tejido cerca a la
superficie llamada fascia del recto
luego el cirujano unirá un extremo del
cabestrillo hecho del propio tejido o
material sintético bajo la uretra y
cerca a la vejiga
unirá el otro extremo alrededor de la
fascia del recto para crear un soporte
tipo hamaca para la uretra
al final del procedimiento el médico
suturar a las incisiones
algunas veces insertará un catéter para
ayudar a drenar la vejiga hasta que
pueda orinar fácilmente por su cuenta
después del procedimiento usted será
trasladado al área de recuperación para
controlarlo y se le suministrarán
antibióticos y otros medicamentos según
sea necesario permanecerá en el hospital
de 1 a 3 días si tiene un procedimiento
de suspensión de vejiga abierta si tiene
un procedimiento laparoscópico
probablemente regrese a su casa el mismo
día de la cirugía